new at 11 tonight new artwork unveiled
just outside of the lifeguard arena in
henderson maybe a couple of years before
the silver knights play there but the
city is ready to welcome them right now
8 news now reporter madison kimbrough
spoke with the architect and joins us
live
outside the arena
yes these metal hockey sticks and
concrete pucks were unveiled today
and this is just another way the city
hopes to revamp the water street plaza
area
here in downtown henderson
[Applause]
the whole idea is having the sticks is
sort of an instagram spot right for
people down here
and kind of you pass through the portal
into the area where people are going to
go
it's a cool design but it wasn't spur of
the moment the city of henderson came up
with the idea to have a competition to
revamp the newly imagined
water street plaza in downtown henderson
the design concept has been over a year
in the making and with the new
association with the knights
the city wanted a way to interact the
two the idea that we came up with was to
have a design build competition
so that we could merge these two
projects together get the best and the
brightest ideas out there
and put it together and kind of fast
track this work to try to get
our work done along the same track as
lifeguard arena
the hockey artwork was built by a local
artist in henderson
another neat fact the way the pucks are
placed it creates great seating areas
and
also prevents vehicles from coming
through and you can't forget the big
screens
there's an led monitor so fans can watch
both the golden and silver nights
and there will soon be shade structures
a splash pad
and a 5 000 square foot grass area for
people to hang out
the kids love it i know my kids when
they see the artwork and the hockey
sticks and all that
just they absolutely love it they
gravitate to it they want to go take
pictures with it
and the city says they hope to have the
revamp finished by this
march reporting live in henderson
madison kimbrough 8 news now
signs are